Spiel jetzt Geburtstagsfeier von Dom und
SK gucken wir wer das bessere Equipment
kriegt und mit dem Equipment wird dann
gekämpft im deathmch geht nicht
kaputt ah gut war gut von uns
beid servus es geh Herz willkommen zu
einer weiteren Folge teamsg heute wieder
mit dem dm von anarta und der Hacker aus
der letzten Folge ist lustigerweise wi
in der Runde schreibt gerade eben schon
sorry obwohl obwohl wir jetzt an an
einmal am Tag aufnehmen anderen Stunde
und
so komplett andere
Aufnahme liegen Jahre dazwischen ich
habe drei Eisen wie war die letz Jahre
bei dir eigentlich so alles gut gewesen
boaher mittlerweile 25
schont ja schon alt neäst du high oder
ich lau meine Route ja alles klar dann
lau ich meine rout
ja Typ hofung dass mich kein typusos
oder ja aber hat NX kom Typus an der
will aber irgendwas von mir od mit
eisenharnisch H ich ganz gerne was könnt
er von dir wollen komm jetzt noch ein
Hit nicht weglaufen nicht weglaufen
junge geil oh fucking Gott oh fucking
geil okay ja Orgasmus ist da gewesen
liebe Leute ich bin alles gut bei mir
nice ich bin full Gold und er will
bestimt gleich runterspringen oder diger
wo willst du lang wo willst du lang du
kleines hchen SPT auf jeden Fall Feuer
das R aber auch nicht einfach he x
Destroyer ja Name geil ne x nur das ist
immer noch besser als XI muss ich sagen
ja okay geht noch K her ich bin Hans
per willst du noch durchgehen lassen
oder Peter
her Peter
hallo
Hans
Mittagessen Lauf mir nicht
weg unverschämt
wie ich nicht durchkomme er durchkommt
ne oh mann e mal Rüchen aber die alles
gut du lebst noch und so ja ja ja bin
noch am leben ja ja gut gut to leider
der Hacker ist schon mal tot ja auf jeed
Fall ausgemacht jetzt ja wahrscheinlich
schon das lustige war ja also habt das
Video wahrscheinlich schon gesehen es
schien mir so ich meine vor 5 Jahren
hochgeladen ich habe ja mittlerweile
auch die Millionen an Subs und Dom auch
wobei er dann knapp nach der Millionen
aufgehört hat weil er die andere
geheiratet hat wie hi die noch mal jetzt
meine ich nicht bredulie sondern die
andere da weiß
du meinst du nein
sag das ist jetzt der Zeit dar du darfst
jetzt eine Person aussuchen die du in 5
Jahren heiraten würdest ja nehme iching
Dash ja Heirat zu ich bin an einem mit
no stuff getötet worden weil ich weil
ich dummerweise kein kein Leben hatte
weil ich schon gegen zwei gekämpft habe
weil ich dummerweise dumm war oder domm
ja es K das tut mir furchtbar leid
gerade hier in chat ja tut dir leid oder
nicht du hast mir die Aufnahme versa
versaut das war elich witzig aber Alter
also noch mal ich bin mit verheiratet
und du bist natürlich auch verheiratet
ne und hast deine 15 Kinder oder ja ich
bin verheiratet mit mit Tim
CCK mit wem W ich verheiratet W aus
kte Youtube Spektrum oder warte mal wer
wie heißt du will K will ich dich
verfolgen ich kann aber nichts weil ich
diger DJ Bomber also DJ bomba willst mir
sagen du hast nich von DJ bomba gehört
ja doch doch ist das nicht von DJ Bobo
so ein Kollege oder so was DJ bom oh
Kacke Kacke peter ist hier
ja mit goldapfelinus und verber
steinchwert und fast vol iron außer
Schuhe er ist Veganer ich hab hab halt
ein FNS was ich einsetzen kann ja geil
ja gut aber er geht nicht so drauf ein
muss ich sagen komm friss mal bitte
friss friss das ist okay er Wasser vi
kann Kapital
schlagenben nice den H
dirn aber
oder wemen muss kururz we ich
goldapfel so mein Lieber jetzt ist es
Zeit drauf
zuehen leider keine am dampfen von Peter
Peter komm
Peter
Leute W fast down gewesen läuft weg
immer dieselben immer immer immer
dieselben immer die P es ist immer immer
das gleiche ja ich ich Spam mal falls
machen will neben sind auch noch mal
zwei die laufen in andere Richtung genau
wie du lustig aus gerade ach m ich
kämpfe gegen ich kämpfe gegen zwei Leute
und beide W ich habe D noch ein halbes
Leben oder so da kommt mir einer mit no
stuff an und Zerbst mich von hinten
weißt du ist immer ja wunderbar
oh ja nice down okay
durch so Pfeile haben wir jetzt auch
scheinbar 15 Pfeile Alter warum hat er
die nicht eingesetzt oh mir fliegt
gerade so so eine Motte ins Gesicht
wunderbar geil e Motte ich habe gesagt
ich die Aufnahme
bastente ja ist wahrscheinlich einfach
wei du kennst diese Motte ja genau die
MS die
MS die sind sind immer sehr sehr
penetrant ja kann nichts machen ja ja
die Mods ja man ich will ein eins gegen
dich machen scha schon wieder nicht was
ist denn da los echt Fluch drin
irgendwie so ein bisschen ne weiß was
wir machen wir schauen mal wie lange die
Runde wird und je nachdem spielen wir
einfach noch mal anderes Ründchen und
nehmen dann dann nur das deathmch auf
und schneiden das hinten dran wo wir
dannil hammergeile Idee oder ja nicht
bei Legend hat one geklappt ja weil ihr
lange gebraucht kommen zum ja wir
wollten wir hatten gar kein food wir
mussten uns von zombieleisch Ernen diger
okay das war grausam okay hier sind drei
Leute
Team Felix und
squ irgendwas ich geh mal lieber nicht
hoch weil im Gebäude gegen zwei Leute
ist immer
scheiße ja aber ja ich guck wie die kipt
sind warte mal kurz ich mal nach oben ja
okay iron
Sword du kannst dir ein absnacken weil
der eine ist AFK der eine ist AFK nee
doch nicht doch nicht doch nicht doch
nicht aber genau das wollte ich sagen du
hich genau von da oben reingehen
goldapfel pass auf den H h dir di diesen
is pass
auf einfach rein warte ja nice nice nice
nice nice nice ich B aber ich B aber
nein diger er ist ir noch sttir
stir piss er V let folgeer e die ganze
Zeit gewartet ja gut Leute ma jetzt ein
kurzen Cut und dann sehen wir uns beim
onev1 wieder oh ja so Leute wieder und
diger ist ja überhaupt niemand in der
Runde oh mein Gott was hier los wir
Spiel wir spielen jetzt das Spiel jetzt
Geburtstagsfeier von Dom und SK du
nimmst die linke Seite der Kisten ich
die Rechte und jetzt gucken wir wer oh
sehr schön Eisenschwert und jetzt gucken
wir wer das bessere Equipment kriegt und
mit dem Equipment wird dann gekämpft im
deathmch wür ich sagen einfach SP was
was ist mit den hier mit den geradeaus
Ding nimm du die innere ich nehme die
äußere okay nee hier warte nein hier
also ich habe schon von da habe ich g
bis da okay okay dann nehme ich die hier
dann darfst du eigentlich quasi beide
nehmen weil ich habe beide außen soll
ich dann beide innen nehmen lst ich
beide nehmen ich hab 1 2 D 4 5 Kisten
sechs Kisten gehabt die eine innen habe
ich schon gemacht so hast jetzt
natürlich ein entsprechendes Problem
ich habe jetzt nicht die OP Rüstung
aber kann nich super enchanten hier das
natürlich
nice wenn ich d mal Level 1 Verzauberung
Kriege und ah sieht schlecht
du hast gute Rüstung ja guten Tag nice
aber aber halt nur ein steinschwert du
hast aber das Eisenschwert ja aber ich
habe Smite drauf okay leider Smite gut
wo woll wir denn kämpfen hier so ein
bisschen hier einfach hier so am Spawn
und so einfach hier so und so ja K wir
machen alles klar okay ja ich bin ready
ready medady alles klar dann
lass sonst
losgehen schreibt mal in die Kommentare
wer die Sache gewinnt Leute oh ja aber
vorher jetzt ja ja jetzt jetzt jetzt
warten mal kurz 10 Sekunden habt ihr
wähendessen drehen wir uns wie wild im
Kreis bitte schn du du gerade du da wenn
du gerade hier du schreibst zu langsam
du genau du Yolo Crafter HD LP mach
mallich den gesehen ne so okay okay sind
ich mer das schon schon hier okay dann
dann go aber ich Sachen nicht zerstören
warum kann ich nicht zerstören die
Sachen hierum geht es nicht kaputt ah
gut war gut von uns beiden da oh oh
jetzt gewinnst du oh nice ja dreieinhalb
Herzen GG ich wollte wollte noch mein
powerbogen einsetzen aber dazu kam ich
gar nicht mehr hat auch nur hat auch nur
ein Pfeil das Eis hat schon ordentlich
ordentlich geraped du hast mir glaube
ich ein du hast mir glaube ich nur drei
stü gegeben ich war tot irgendwie be
drei oder vier schägen irgendwie
eventuell hatte ich doch scharnes drauf
und nicht smile also weiß man nicht so
genau ne hatest du Schärfe drauf ja hab
ich gesag okay dann ist es klar das ein
besseres dichwert quasi dann ist das
schon ultra ja ja Leute wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann lasst ein Daumen nach
oben da Dom ist in der Beschreibung
gerne abchecken und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten Video wieder mach's gut
haut rein
und